Take a look at these two blue circles.
The blue circle on the right looks slightly larger than the blue circle on the left.
Actually, this is an illusion.
When something is surrounded by large objects, it looks relatively small.
Take away the surrounding objects...
...and you can see that the blue circles are actually the same size.
The same type of illusion affects your waistline.
When you place a portion of food onto a small plate,...
...it looks relatively large, and so you often end up putting less on the plate.
In fact, psychologist Brian Wansink has discovered...
...that just moving from a 12-inch to a ten-inch plate....
...causes people to eat around 20% less.
So if you want to lose weight the easy way, simply switch to smaller plates.